The decision to end this sci-fi cult favorite
after two seasons has already been made, but
why exactly did Netflix execs decide to pull
the plug on their mind-bending mystery thriller?
Here are a few reasons why we think The OA
was canceled.
Netflix doesn't release its viewing figures,
so it's impossible to say whether the amount
of people streaming The OA impacted the decision
to axe it.
What we do know is that the streamer makes
these decisions based on a simple ratio: viewership
versus cost.
Netflix has confirmed that it adheres to this
formula, and according to The Wrap, an insider
with knowledge of Netflix's decision to cancel
the drama two seasons in has confirmed that
The OA fell on the wrong side of the equation.
The OA was "a big creative swing" for the
company, the source said, and while it was
one that Netflix was "proud to take" it just
wasn't paying off.
In June 2019, Netflix chief content officer
Ted Sarandos reportedly ordered dozens of
his TV and movie execs to rein in their spending.
People familiar with the high-level meeting
told The Information it was made clear that
bigger budget projects needed to bring in
the viewers going forward — building buzz
and industry credibility was no longer enough.
The Netflix business model relies not only
on the retention of subscribers, but the steady
influx of new ones, and shows like The OA
don't help in that department.
It was critically acclaimed, yes, but the
Netflix metric deemed that it was no longer
a draw.
As a report by The Information put it,
"Netflix has learned that the first two seasons
of a show are key to bringing in subscribers
— but the third and later seasons don't
do much to retain or win new subscribers.
Ending a show after the second season saves
money, because showrunners who oversee production
tend to negotiate a boost in pay after two
years."
Understandably, this approach isn't popular
with producers, especially those running shows
designed to be told over multiple seasons,
like The OA.
One creator of a Netflix show that was axed
after two seasons alleged,
"It's really hard to get [Netflix] to put
money into a third season.
For a creator, you want to be able to reward
your audience with more seasons."
She's Gotta Have It, American Vandal and Friends
From College, all canceled in 2019, also only
got two seasons.
Netflix has denied that this is a new policy.
On the surface, The OA is your typical binge-worthy
Netflix show, teasing viewers with glimpses
of what's to come in order to keep them rooted
in their seats for hours on end.
That relationship between show and viewer
only functions if the build up to those glimpses
is satisfying enough in its own right, however,
and in the case of The OA, it was very much
a one-sided relationship.
Simply put, The OA required viewers to sit
through hours of speculative twists and turns
for ultimately very little payoff in return.
Questions were answered with questions that
lead to yet more questions.
While traditional TV networks may be willing
to churn out endless episodes of a show based
on mystery alone, much like ABC's Lost, Netflix
isn't going to continue to fund a show that
loses people's interest before they get to
the payoff.
The OA isn't for everybody.
It's wildly imaginative and incredibly well
executed, but its mysteries are often a bit
too impenetrable.
Part I ended with a school shooting, thwarted
by, for the sake of clarity, what we'll call
"interpretive dance."
One character swallows a sea anemone during
a near-death experience, in the same episode
in which another character swallows a bird
given to her by an angel with braille on her
face.
The OA Part II is equally weird, and, for
some critics, it just went too far.
According to IndieWire's Ben Travers, Part
II, "doubles down in a longer, more pretentious,
and less vigorous follow-up season that's
part puzzle box, part romance, and wholly
insane."
If there's one single moment in season two
of The OA that seemed to push people over
the edge, it's when Brit Marling's "original
angel" meets a telepathic octopus.
Yes, a telepathic octopus.
We had already been through a whole lot of
craziness by the time the show's protagonist
encounters this creature, whose name, by the
way, is "Old Night."
"I hold hope for your species."
"He holds hope for our species."
This extraordinary octopus communicates with
revellers at a packed nightclub via our dimension-traversing
hero, and it was simply too much for some
viewers.
Even ardent fans of the show were left utterly
perplexed by what they had witnessed, and,
in true OA fashion, answers weren't exactly
forthcoming.
"What the f--- is this?"
"I just do lights, bro."
One of the biggest issues with The OA is that
it seemed to be catering almost exclusively
to a cult audience.
The show built up a dedicated following after
its first season, and rather than trying to
expand that following by making season two
a little more accessible to new viewers, The
OA seemed to lean even further into the weirdness.
The result was a second season that isolated
anyone that didn't have the patience for telepathic
octopuses and dancing robots, and isolating
potential customers isn't part of the Netflix
business model.
Could the fact that The OA pandered to its
fandom a little too much have been a factor
in Netflix pulling the plug?
According to Slashfilm's Joshua Meyer, the
show seemed to take pleasure in the fact that
it created an exclusive club for people who
were willing to go along with whatever it
threw at them.
Meyer wrote in his review of The OA Part II,
"It gathers fans around itself in a candlelit
attic and seeks to regale them with a tall
tale.
The show has big ideas, but its characters
are all too quick to chase magic mirrors on
blind faith.
If you're invested in those characters, then
you might be willing to drink from the same
pitcher of Kool-Aid that they do."
Could co-creators of The OA Brit Marling and
Zal Batmanglij already be working on another
project for Netflix?
Their first show might be done, but the language
that Marling used when she took to Instagram
following news of The OA's cancellation seemed
to suggest that something else could be in
the pipeline.
The actress and producer posted,
"We feel profound gratitude to Netflix and
the people we have worked with there for making
it possible to make Part I and Part II.
While we cannot finish this story, I can promise
you we will tell others."
Those other stories could well be told via
a different platform, but Netflix's statement
on the matter also suggested that their relationship
with Marling and Batmanglij wasn't over.
Cindy Holland, vice president of original
content for Netflix, said in a statement,
"We are incredibly proud of the 16 mesmerizing
chapters of The OA and are grateful to Brit
and Zal for sharing their audacious vision.
We look forward to working with them again
in the future, in this and perhaps many other
dimensions."
There's no denying that Marling is a huge
talent with more to offer, and the "dark flair"
that Batmanglij brought as director of The
OA didn't go unnoticed.
Here's hoping this daring duo works together
again soon, and gets to see their wild visions
play out in full.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.